sometimes the best things come up in the
commercial break and the commercial
break you told me that at the bar mitzva
you drugged your stepmom yeah you know
she smokes pipe back in the day and she
felt she could handle it and we split an
edible piece of marijuana and first of
all I need to tell you my son mother
just like to get an essence of her her
name is Janice she's the most wonderful
woman in the world she's got you have to
do an impression of her with nails like
you know you've gotta be holding them
like this and she says things like I
feel like a good way to get to know her
is one time I she had a new painting in
the house and I said oh what a beautiful
painting and she goes isn't it great
it's all my colors tan bronze and animal
prints we get really high yeah and she
gets very high in a new way she has an
experience because you gave her an
edible and those things are powerful I'm
told my sister Jody and I we're trying
to remember the things the greatest
things you said one was um I can feel my
clothes I had to tell Carolyn Holman cuz
because she could see right through me
oh my god and then um oh she said that
man is so tall and then Joe Dean had to
say up mom you're sitting and he's
standing and she was like oh and
she's a lot of fun when she's high she
was sure she could smell colors yeah
yeah well it does your deck does your
dad smoke pot as well
yeah neither of them really like imbibe
on any kind of regular basis but my dad
when he comes to town will have a poker
game because my dad I grew up with him
he plays poker every Monday Tuesday or
Wednesday anyway that's a long story and
so we'll have a game and a few years ago
a while ago now he came and we had a
poker game and Jeff Ross not to be
confused with you're Jeffrey right yeah
we have a Jeffrey right avid Jeff Ross
the producer of you have but Jeffrey
Ross who does a lot of the roasts a very
funny comic the roastmaster general he
brought a giant red white and blue bong
which he later named the joints chief of
staff
my dad took the hugest bong hit I was
having a heart attack I was like dad
it's stronger than it used to be in your
day and he took like a champ like the I
I don't smoke from bongs I'm a grown
woman it was crazy there was so much
smoke came out of his mouth and I was
freaking out and he loved about I was
freaking out he goes you know what Sarah
I'm positive I can fly and it hit him
very hard I think he played one more
hand of Poker and then the bedroom was
downstairs and he said I'm going to bed
and I remember Jeff Ross yelling after
him I'll be down in a few minutes and
they had an incredible time wasn't that
a great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]